Mit Industriewürze im Huhn fordert
Sebastian Lege den Sternekoch Frank
Buchholz zum Geschmacksduell heraus.
Sebastian möchte wissen, ob sein Turbohuhn
oder die Luxusversion vom Sternekoch den
Schnabel vorne hat.
Industrieware schmeckt oft viel besser als der Preis
vermuten lässt, möglich macht das eine
Zutat namens "Würze". Geschmacksverstärker
wie Glutamat sind zwar unbeliebt, doch
versteckt in wohlklingenden Zutaten wie
"Hefeextrakt" finden sie sogar in Bio-Ware
Verwendung, vor allem bei Fertiggerichten.
Dank Industriewürze schmeckt auch
minderwertiges Fleisch lecker.
Zum Beweis fordert Sebastian Lege den
Sternekoch und Fleischexperten Frank
Buchholz zum Grillduell.
-Frank!
-Sebastian! Alter Rocker du.
Der Lebensmitteltechnologe behauptet, er
bekommt das Billighuhn vom Discounter
genauso lecker hin wie der Spitzenkoch
sein Edel-Geflügel.
Meine Großmutter war eine Metzgersgattin, die hat immer gesagt günstige Mädchen
taugen nichts. Da sag ich hier, diese
Weiber, die sind meiner Meinung nach
nichts wert.
-Aber ist natürlich auch immer eine
Preisfrage, was kostet
dein Hühnchen im Kilo?
-Bestimmt deutlich teurer
als das, das geht ja auch gar nicht anders.
-Sag mal nur einmal, zweimal, dreimal teurer? Das würde mir
schon reichen.
-Ich würde sagen viermal teurer.
-Viermal teurer!
Heißt im Klartext: So ein
französischer Luxus-Gockel kostet mit
Haut und Knochen über 12€ pro
Kilo.
Sebastian Leges pure Hühnerbrust vom
Discounter gibt es dagegen für weniger als
4€ pro Kilo.
Klar hat das Fleisch nicht dieselbe Qualität,
doch diesen Nachteil sollen nun bewährte
Industriezutaten wieder ausgleichen.
Als da wären: Wasser, Salz, flüssiges
Raucharoma für die Grillnote und
natürlich Hefeextrakt für einen
intensiveren Fleischgeschmack.
So, jetzt habe ich hier ein bisschen Hefeextrakt.
Ist dann so
nach Glutamat die nächste
Erfindung gewesen, um den Leuten so einen
vollmundigen Geschmack zu erzeugen. Man
kennt das aus dieser kleinen Flasche, die
ganz gerne zur Erbsensuppe gereicht wird.
-Was kostet so ein Kilo Hefeextrakt?
-3€.
-Noch ein bisschen Wasser, ein bisschen Rauchöl, ne?
-Ja, also falls du mal Kosten optimieren musst..
Konzentrierte Würze, Fleischgeschmack
ohne Fleisch. Die Erfindung dieses
Prinzips war so etwas wie der Big Bang
der Lebensmittelindustrie. In den 1850er Jahren erfindet Justus von Liebig
ein Verfahren, aus Fleisch konzentrierten
Extrakt herzustellen.
Ein riesiger Verkaufserfolg.
Doch dann macht ein junger Schweizer
namens Julius Maggi die Entdeckung
seines Lebens. Das gleiche Verfahren
funktioniert auch mit Getreideschrot.
Stundenlang gekocht, in Salzsäure
zersetzt, mit Natronlauge neutralisiert -
heraus kommt eine salzige Brühe mit
herzhaft fleischigem Geschmack, ganz ohne
teures Fleisch. Für Millionen Menschen
ein riesiger Fortschritt. Heute eine
Zutat, mit der die Industrie Fleisch aus
Massenproduktion geschmacklich aufpeppt.
Damit sie ihre Wirkung optimal entfaltet,
spritzt Lege die Flüssigwürze ins
Fleisch.
Ein beliebter Trick um neben Geschmack
auch zusätzliches Gewicht und damit mehr
Profit zu erzielen.
Sternekoch Frank Buchholz sieht es mit Grausen.
Seine Gäste erwarten da schon mehr.
Das sieht auf jeden Fall nicht unbedingt
vielversprechend aus, das Fleisch, wenn ich das mal sagen darf.
In der Edelgastronomie zählt naturgemäß
nicht der günstige Preis, sondern das
Besondere. Und dazu gehört für Frank
Buchholz auch die Haltungsform der Tiere.
120 Tage hatte sein Huhn Zeit zu wachsen
und schmackhaftes Fleisch zu entwickeln.
Viermal mehr als Hühner aus dem Schnellmastbetrieb. Deshalb vertraut Buchholz
voll auf den natürlichen Geschmack. Mehr
als eine ordentliche Prise Salz braucht
sein Vogel nicht, dann kommt er so wie er
ist auf den Grill.
Jetzt möchte ich mal sehen,
was du jetzt da so drauf hast. Wie das so
weitergeht mit der ganzen Spritzerei.
Ja, das wird gleich noch spannend.
Das kann man wohl sagen, denn Sebastian
Leges so genannte Grillhühnchen bekommen
niemals einen Grill zu Gesicht.
Stattdessen garen sie bei 120 Grad im
Ofen, damit möglichst viel vom
aufgespritzten Gewicht erhalten bleibt.
Tada! Und?
Ja was und? Das hat mit Grillen nichts zu
tun, das sie traurig aus.
Aber der Produktentwickler ist ja auch
noch längst nicht fertig. Schritt 1
zur Grill-Optik aus der Retorte: Paprika
Farbe.
Schritt 2: Brandspuren, nur eine Sache von
Sekunden.
Fehlt nur noch das Grillmuster. Aber für
Sebastian Lege gibt es nichts, was sich
nicht im Schnellverfahren imitieren
lässt. Zeit ist Geld.
Entschuldige, aber jetzt zeige ich dir mal
wie Geflügel aussieht, wenn es ganz
normal ohne Theater zubereitet wird
und wenn ich das jetzt vergleiche, was ja
nicht wirklich vergleichbar ist.
Lege ahnt es schon, das Luxus-Huhn
schmeckt auch ohne Würzhilfe lecker.
Schön!
Na das wird ja mal ein Fest heute hier.
So einfach wie es aussieht ist es nicht,
denn ohne die Erfahrung eines
Grillprofis, kann das auch schief gehen.
Ja, aber ich sage mal, das Problem ist ja
meistens bei so einem ganzen Tier
sensorisch oft, die Brust zu trocken und
die Schenkel noch nicht durch.
Aber es geht nun mal nur um den Geschmack.
Einfach das schmeckt nach glücklichem
Huhn!
-Saftig ist doch lecker, gehört auch
zum Geschmack dazu!
-Das schmeck erstmal nach
glücklichem Huhn.
-Ein bisschen hart?
-Da brauch man ne Kreissäge.
Ob das mit Flüssigwürze aufgepumpte
Industriehähnchen da mithalten kann?
Sebastian Lege ist gespannt wie
Sternekoch Frank Buchholz sein Billig-
Huhn findet.
-Wenn wir überlegen, wir haben jetzt bei mir Hefeextrakt drin, Salz drin, dann Raucharoma drinnen.
Hätte schlimmer werden können.
Nicht schlecht, besser als ich erwartet
habe, muss ich ganz ehrlich sagen.
-Oder?
-Ja, nicht schlecht.
-Und ich sage mal, der "Durchschnittsdeutsche",
der natürlich sehr fleischlastig ist, auch
in seiner Ernährung, muss auf solche
Produkte zurückgreifen, die
dementsprechend auch..
-Also müssen tut er
schon mal gar nicht, wenn du das
sein lassen würdest, dann hast du auch
nicht das Problem, dass du so oft ein
schlechtes Gewissen hast, wenn du
einschläfst und dann dem lieben Gott
noch mal sagst: "Ich grill zwar gerne,
aber ich möchte doch lieber in den Himmel!"
-Ja, richtig.
Spitzenqualität hat auch ihren Preis,
doch günstige Produkte für geringere
Ansprüche verkaufen sich einfach besser.
Und dank Würze hat das Billig-Huhn
sogar dem Sternekoch erstaunlich gut
geschmeckt.
Was sind eure Würz- und Marinadetricks
auf dem Grill? Sagt es uns in den
Kommentaren.
Und wenn ihr noch mehr über eure
Lebensmittel wissen wollt, schaut die
nächsten zwei Clips und abonniert die
ZDFbesseresser!